bone model and its Castle through the
woods was far from the ceremony of a
state funeral
the world's eye had been on the estate
by the river D on the day the queen died
here
the day of her funeral saw traffic free
roads
closed shops and quiet streets
in balator the village the queen knew as
a neighbor the funeral was an occasion
to share with a nation indoors and on
screen
the street scene featured only a few who
ventured out in respect and Remembrance
it's very emotional
Our Queen too
and um it's really special to be here
the thing that I think has impacted me
most has been the pictures of her smile
and how we'll never see that smile again
from her
[Music]
balloter had paid its respects publicly
the night before the funeral with a
gathering in the Village Square
there was remembrance too at the Kelpie
sculpture and Falkirk where 96 candles
were lit one for every year of the
Queen's life
this was the scene at gordonston school
in Moray at Windmill Lodge The Boarding
House of Prince Charles the former pupil
who became king cotton students gathered
to watch the spectacle down south
Hollywood Park over the wall from the
Queen's official Palace residence people
were invited to watch the funeral on a
big screen
two miles north for the Royal yacht
Britannia is today anchored as a tourist
attraction they remembered a monarch now
gone and times passed it was her own
private
um
domain
um and to see is so relaxed when you can
see it laughing and joking it was
unbelievable
the scene here at the gates of the
Balmoral estate is quieter than it was
people are still coming but not in the
same numbers
the focus of the Queen's passing and the
nation working through it has shifted
South
we've heard Paul Anderson play violin
before but not this particular tune
the Fiddler who played for the queen
composed this a lament for Queen
Elizabeth following her death he played
it for us where he used to play for her
inside krathy cooked she always wasn't
right to the end and seemed to enjoy it
I mean I usually would get we smile at
the end of the the performance which it
was a nice thing to to see I think a lot
of folk have spoken about each other a
nice smile at twinkle and her eye and I
I suppose that's something I would
remember and just that little Personal
Touch how we know it at the end in our
smile
on the day of her funeral the people of
Royal d-side were 500 miles from a queen
they held dear but feelings here aren't
diminished by distance
James Matthews Sky News in balita
[Music]